the United States had its least bad day in terms
of covid yesterday that it has had in nearly six
months dating all the way back to September of
twenty twenty. Now, we were worried after seeing
a precipitous decline starting in mid-January
in cases and deaths and hospitalizations
that it was leveling out and even averages
crept up for a period of about four or five
days a couple of weeks ago. That has now further
reversed and we are on the way back down. And
that is such welcome. Good news. We're for a year
there has been very little good news. This is our
weekly covid update. Deaths continue down, cases
continue down. Hospitalizations continue down as
vaccinations continue climbing now averaging more
than two point one million vaccinations a day
over the last week. Let's go through them one by
one. First of all, cases, remember, cases peaked
on January 11th at an average of two hundred
and fifty five thousand cases per day,
an insane number. We are now down 77 percent
to about 58000 cases a day over the last
week. Still a long way to go. Remember, Dr.
Fauci says we can't really think about normality
until we, of course, have way more people
vaccinated. But until cases get below 10000
cases a day, but being down 77 percent is a great
thing. Secondly, deaths, deaths peaked with an
average of about 3400 deaths a day, more than
a 9/11 a day. In the last few days of January,
deaths are down to a still tragic sixteen
hundred per day. That is a decline of 53 percent.
It's an indicator that things are going in the
right direction. It's hard to feel good about
six hundred people a day dying and I don't
feel good about it. But at least we are down
to that number. Rather than seeing deaths climb,
remember that deaths lag cases by several weeks.
So we would hope that in a few weeks we would be
down 77 percent in deaths the way we are down 77
percent in cases today. Next indicator, and
this is increasingly an important indicator
that deaths lag cases by a period of time.
Cases also depend on testing. Hospitalizations
is a really important indicator to be looking
at as people get vaccinated. Hospitalizations,
new hospitalizations daily are down from their
peak of about 18000 people going into the hospital
each day with covid in mid-January, 18000 was
the peak, down to about 5000 a day lately. Again,
hard to feel good about every day 5000 people
have to go into the hospital because of covid,
but it's a decline of 72 percent that is huge.
And then total cumulative people in the hospital.
At one point we had one hundred and twenty five
thousand people in the US hospitalized with covid.
That is down to thirty thousand. That's a decline
in hospitalizations of 76 percent. So these
are dramatically improving numbers that muskaan.
Continue to decline. Now, what about the variance?
I have good news about variance. The fear is the
vaccines won't work against variants. That's been
the fear. We have a New England Journal of
Medicine report of the three major variants,
the three major variants are what's called the
Bee one one seven variant. That's the UK variant,
the B thirteen fifty one variant. That's the
South African variant. And then the P one variant,
which is the Brazilian variant. A study looked at
neutralization of those variants with serum from
people who have been vaccinated fully to Fizer
doses. And then you wait the one to two weeks.
The data is very good. I'm putting up a
complicated image for our video audience.
If it if it looks confusing, don't
worry. What we are looking at here
are these three variants I mentioned, plus two
subsets of the South African variant, all of the
serum sample. So the idea is you get serum from
vaccinated people. The serum has antibodies. Those
serum samples efficiently neutralized all of
the virus variants. That is really good news.
But let's let's be cautious. The cautious
piece is basically two things. Number one,
primarily with the South African variant
and secondarily with the Brazilian variant,
the level of neutralization is closer to
the minimum necessary to defeat the virus.
So what that means is the vaccines appear to be
enough in most cases to defeat these variants.
But it's closer to borderline, which means that
in some people, if you don't generate as many
antibodies because the antibody generation is
on a on a distribution curve and some people
will be at the lower end of the curve, which can
be by chance or due to a condition that affects
your immune system. It will be more borderline
whether the vaccine will completely protect you
from the South African or Brazilian variants.
It would be closer to escaping the vaccine.
But in most people, you will not you will be
protected. And even if you're not in most people
who don't get enough protection against those
variants, you would get a very mild, mild illness,
a cold sniffles, et cetera. Last sort of caveat,
these are serum tests in labs in the real world
with people you would expect that it would not
be as open and shut as the data is in these serum
tests. But it is still as reassuring as we would
hope based on the significant doom and gloom about
the variance escape. The vaccine period does
not appear to be true based on everything we
know right now. So let's keep it going. This
is not the time to ease up. Let's continue to
to to push for the declines. And we're within
months of a significant return to normalization
if we can keep going on vaccination and doing
what. But most states have been doing remember
March 26th, one day membership blowout? We had an
unfortunately really bad month from the standpoint
of membership's in February. A lot of people still
hit with the economic destruction of the virus,
having to cancel their memberships. February being
a shorter month, not as many people signing up. So
we are doing a one day membership special. The
theme of it will be vaccine related and it'll be
March twenty sixth. If you want to be notified
about that special, just get on my mailing
list at David Pakman dot com and you will get a
perfect email on the morning of March 26 telling
you how to avail yourself of this discount.
And of course, let me know how things are going
in your state as far as vaccinations go.
By finding me on Twitter at Dipak